i was gonna ask what's what's next then
what do you what are you what's uh
what do you want to do next like because
you've done you've done everything i
swear right yeah i really don't know i
you know i
we had gochi gang season two and all the
guests completely mapped out
and then we had to drop it and we
postponed it postponed it and then now
it's like completely in limbo
um and you know the u.s is like doing
pretty well with vaccinations so i think
that's what they're like really banking
on so the timeline is starting to kind
of speed up
where they can kind of see the the light
at the end of the tunnel
but man it's really hard cause i just
i'm trying to make sure that that
happens beyond anything else
um it's hard to get invested in anything
right now it really is and i don't want
to have my heart broken so
it's literally just just don't get my
hopes up it's it's literally just been
thoughtful
tell me when it happens and then i can
get excited about it yeah but
um as we talked about before twitch is
very interesting um
but also i've been doing a lot more
voice acting because
a lot of the studios especially like
more indie gaming studios have become
more flexible with their audio specs
right so
they're they're okay with like you
sending stuff from home and
so that's looking really fun and good
during this like
like pandemic period yeah but genuinely
i don't even like really know
i'm just trying to figure it out i'm
just trying to figure it out and i think
it's almost
okay that we take the time that's like
what else are we supposed to do other
than like kind of introspect right now
yeah cause like it's like do you have a
favorite kind of like
industry or topic that you like to work
in because you've worked in so many
different
like industries and stuff ah you know i
do like hosting
um i think that is really where i
trained the most in so to speak and i'm
the most comfortable
uh being like told what to say but also
have an impact because you're almost
like
you're in a weird position where it's
like people know you as like
a youtuber i know right but you don't
really consider yourself a youtuber
i mean it's not like a bad thing um like
i would dirty word
did you just call me a content creator
i mean in a way like i actually think
it's more impressive
to be a youtuber where i like really
wanted to be that instead of like a host
that's hired for stuff
i don't know man like i think a host
looks way more likely i mean like whoa
that's cool yeah i it's like it's kind
of hard to sell i guess it's my mood on
the day
yeah yeah yeah you're like damn
consistent employment that must be nice
right yeah but then i'm like oh but then
i guess your your
earnings are capped at some point and
your like growth potential is definitely
right but
i do miss working with like a technical
team i miss
having like a co-host um and i guess
i miss like a professional aspect of it
although it's not like youtube isn't
professional it's just
having to take care of every aspect of
it yourself and then if it comes
crashing down it crashes down on you and
you implode
that's really frightening it is super
nice just being able to turn up and then
just do the thing and leave yeah
it's pretty good because because like
like i feel like i'm really quite
technologically current right but
even even like streaming for me yeah
it's it's like confusing at times
right like just just having to set up
and having to learn especially looking
at connor's setup which just
which connor says it's easy i'm going to
be like no it's not easy
i've said it before like you could do it
too i'm like okay well okay this weighs
like i can like dumb it down
like take away some things that you
don't need like all these all the live
sound effects and
bones yeah well i mean you know
literally like the stream deck alone
will up the quality of your stream it's
like this tiny little thing with like
12 buttons that will just change things
or play sounds or do certain things
and it makes it so much more
professional like and makes it so
much easier yeah because i used to have
to like pull up the software
scroll to the thing i wanted to click
and then change it to like this screen
so if i want to be like okay show all of
my face all right scroll
all the time i actually want to change
it back to the game now but now it's
like press the buttons on the side
yeah but like there's also times where
you know with this kind of setup
for some reason you know you you changed
one setting or something
uh you changed one setting you don't
remember you did and for some reason the
sound from your game or the sound chat
is just not coming out yeah
there's always a technical issue and you
just have to go through this to-do list
where you're just checking okay is this
is this setting correct is that setting
correct i don't even remember
what i did to set this up to begin with
you know it just adds a layer of
complexity yeah
i do think that there's like such a
forgiveness in streaming right
like anybody that is your fan that's
watching you oh i think
they find it charming that you have to
not like fumble around
but it's very real right to be like oh
sorry like technical air like let me fix
it and you're kind of there for the
journey
i guess that's kind of like the
bittersweet moment right because like
there have been some moments where i'm
like
there is something wrong with my stream
and i cannot
completely forgot to [ __ ] figure it
out but like it's kind of like nice to
be like just
you'd be like oh [ __ ] sorry guys you
know i'm trying to fix this thing i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is i don't
want to end the stream because
we just started yeah and this is you
know like hundreds of people just being
like
it's all good bro yeah yeah we'll wait
i don't know about that because i i i i
get that because i
you know a lot of people in the comment
section are supportive but then
you go you start going through technical
difficulties and then you see that live
view account drop and it just it never
feels good
if it's something little it's whatever
but if it's like stream like crashing
worthy like it's
very stressful yeah yeah i i
accidentally showed my youtube
um like all my analytics one time on on
really
like a second yeah yeah just
accidentally hit the wrong tab
yeah i actually shared the wrong thing
and i was like yeah guys alright that's
how much i made this spot right
address which is awful that was
the most that was just the most
stressful
like realization we're getting ddos
like like instant sinking feeding to be
like okay i gotta i gotta [ __ ] sort
this out all right
i literally unplugged my internet
unplugged everything i'm just like
google how do i how do i change my ip
address parking l
yeah don't basically don't go on uh
don't test your speed or don't go down
oh you stream oh yeah don't test speed i
didn't realize my
my ip address was right there how did
you save it what did you do
did you share it luckily luckily it
wasn't that
complicated because i googled it all you
have to do to like change because i
don't have a static ip address and all i
had to do was like unplug
unplug yeah yeah yeah plug it in again
but i i don't know at the time i was
just like
well my internet's [ __ ] yeah because i
feel like
how you handle the [ __ ] up is like the
most important part
yeah and then like when i flashed my
thing i'm like oh you know what guys
i'll just [ __ ] show you just have a
look
you're gonna look at the clip just have
a look like all right then i was like
all right so i know it seems like a lot
there's a lot of just an estimate
youtube takes forty percent
you know youtube takes a car you know
there's a lot of costco involved
like it's really easy to look at that
number you know
i'm like you know tax is like 40 it's
pretty you know it's pretty brutal you
know
so basically i see none of them what i'm
trying to say is i'm broke thanks for
the ten dollar donation by the way uh
i'm kidding like that's why i tell
people i'm streaming like i i don't
stream because like i wanna like some
people do excel like i wanna get more
subs
i just do it because i like playing the
game i don't like playing games alone
anymore
for me i don't know why i think that's
probably a bad thing that i've ruined
gaming alone for myself right i only
like
gaming with an audience now i don't know
what this is about me this is what's
wrong with me man
that's like literally the only thing
that's stopping me from like fully
committing to twitch
is the fact that i don't want another
one of my hobbies to turn into a job
i completely understand yes oh that
that's also my other
yeah i was falling out of love with
gaming and i think twitch really saved
it for me and that's why like when i'm
streaming always like yeah dude
you know you can sub if you want but
like i really don't care if like you
know you don't need to i'm doing this
regardless
yeah yeah and uh yeah i just hope people
believe them when i say that it's so
easy to sound like [ __ ] when you say